hello the internet welcome to this limo
guys video dan is nowhere to be found
I hope he doesn't mind I've stepped into
his jacket I'm steve-o insanely jealous
of your guys balloons popping in slow
motion and on a mission to take it to a
whole new level with a fire-breathing
backflip
you ready for war uh how's it going the
question is how much will the balloon
hold while it's hanging suspended there
I guess it's better than there is yeah
it's like a blue nutsack right now Crais
is on it
I don't say this lightly but I think
that's an absolute masterpiece ah it
doesn't even look that impressive
Richburg now oh god it looks like Johnny
Knoxville's nutsack really does here's
how it works
lamp oil goes in my mouth rubbing
alcohol goes on my hand I light my hand
on fire I use it as a torch i backflips
simultaneously blowing the fire the fire
ball hits the balloon ideally I would
land right here and the balloon will pop
from the fire and water land on me
it's a tall order really told when I was
in the circus backstage I'd be icing my
hand so that wouldn't blister up when I
light it on fire there was a clown and
my job was to make kids cry
oh my god those clothes
no tell that our you
your boy
oh my god yeah that was perfect I did I
know what to do now that's perfect
it was perfect yeah yeah I miss your
balloon
and we're back when we clear
Oh tables on fire
we
haha yes dear carpeting on that oh come
on that is so cool
that's good I was idea that was my
vision man you [__] I gave it to you
wasn't easy but I did it
how many times is they then I would
guess honestly 9 or 10 backflips I would
say too I think maybe more least 11 or
12 I don't know I don't know what a
counter it if you want to see lots more
wild crap check out my channel and the
amazing new video I filmed with Kat Von
D you must see it York also follow some
twitter by a slo-mo shirt subscribing
all that stuff steve-o this was amazing
bit moist
okay don't use this to blow the fireball
and I'm not teaching people a today
don't don't do this period you almost
tell everyone